we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemails from the eggman now i need to
give you some background the eggman
lives in rural upstate new york and he's
told us before that he lives in a
relatively low income area and that he
lives in a quite conservative area and
works mostly with conservatives and he
left a voicemail explaining the way that
conversations are taking place about
health care premiums going up and his
co-workers and the people around him
blaming obama care which of course makes
no sense and i'll tell you in a second
why take a listen to this i just want to
give you a little hint also on why
democrats are losing I just had a
quarterly meeting of my company 120
employees pessoa three honest discussing
how the health care costs are going up
next year by three five seven percent
whatever it is he literally blamed
Obamacare
he said because of Obamacare we're still
stuck on the blah blah blah and after
eight so doing the best we can and it
goes up this much so you have
conservative owners telling stupid
factory workers that Obamacare is
causing their insurance rates to go up
instead of owning the fact that Donald
Trump did not fix or change something he
swore he was gonna do it before he was
elected so on that's how they keep
winning
yeah I mean listen I don't know if it's
a strategy or ignorance but I said it
I've been saying this for years the
states that choose or let me put a
different way there are states that
chose not to do the Medicaid expansion
under Obamacare they were mostly red
states I think they were all red states
I'm saying mostly because I don't have
the list in my mind those states tend to
not have very good health care systems
access cost all of that stuff and we
knew that the residents of those states
rather than holding their governor
accountable for not doing the Medicaid
expansion we're going to say I'm in
rough shape with regard to health care
because of Obamacare of course the
opposite is true your governor opted not
to participate in the expansion of
Medicaid in your state the problem is
ignoring Obamacare not Obamacare in and
of itself and there
much bigger overarching issues that we
can talk about here including criticisms
of Obamacare and Barack Obama's week
starting negotiation point on Obamacare
but the eggman points out something
really important which is that narrative
is more powerful than truth and that
part of the reason as he says that the
Democrats keep losing is that the
narratives that Republicans have spun
YES on the backs of ignorant voters no
doubt about it a really effective this
big thing Obamacare happened and yet our
premiums keep coming up Obamacare must
be the reason even though premiums have
been going up for decades and they went
up more slowly within the Obamacare
exchanges rather than outside of them
glazed over right it's too long we've
already lost the thread as far as that
goes
so the this goes back to you can't
convince those people to vote a
different way and I don't encourage you
to try to do it
oh yeah I talked to trump astonish oh
I'm doing a show in my personal life I'm
not trying to convince people not to
support Donald Trump it's a waste of
time the way to win elections is to get
the half of the electorate that already
agrees with us but doesn't vote simply
to go out and vote that's what we need
to do and the Eggman's anecdote is
disturbing and and disheartening as it
is is just more evidence of that we have
a tremendous bonus show for you today
there are some newly released recordings
of Ronald Reagan referring to monkeys
from African countries not good not good
we will talk about that a 10 year old
boy has been charged with assault for
injuring a classmate in a dodgeball like
game we will talk about what's going on
there
and then I have some interesting stories
about this next one one in four food
delivery drivers reportedly admit to
eating some of your food in a recent
study I have some specific stories
involving none other than the delicacy
known as crab rangoon to tell you about
regarding that make sure that you're
following me on instagram at David
Pakman 4 video of my tomato plants yes
urban gardening people up in arms about
all of the ways in which I am
incorrectly pruning my tomato plants
people have a lot of time on their
that's on my Instagram page at David
Pakman and make sure to get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
and and and make sure you're following
me on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman we did our first twitch stream
this week and potentially potentially
plenty more where that came from
we'll speak to you on the bonus show in
just a few minutes